FRANK ACKERMAN:
First about issues
of cost benefit analysis,
if we're doing it,
and then come back to
the issues that Lee
outlined about what's wrong
with cost benefit analysis.
Because whether
or not you believe
something is wrong with it,
many decisions are made with it.
So, well first of all, I'm
impressed at what everyone
has done here and
particularly people
doing this level of
presentation cold and level
of impersonation of
participants in the debate
is very impressive.
You seem to have grasped
most of the things
that I would end up talking
about in cost benefit
analysis in an initial
discussion of it, so let
me try to move on to some of
the more difficult or advanced
issues that I think are
touched on indirectly.
The first speaker
mentioned the willingness
to pay or willingness to accept.
This is a distinction that
sounds almost the same.
They turn out to be extremely
different in practice.
And economists who have
written about methods
have pretty much come to
a consensus on willingness
to pay.
I'm not sure that
it's necessarily
for that great reason.
One of the things it said
is that people feel strongly
about the environment, they
might have ridiculously high
willingness to accept values
that they wouldn't accept
damage unless you
offered them an absurdly
large amount of money.
But I mean, that might be
data rather than a problem
in the analysis.
Nonetheless, the practice has
settled on willingness to pay.
I think there's a
question about what
do the numbers mean if the
costs and benefits are not
comparably monetized.
I think lurking behind
the whole discussion
is the assumption
that the cost benefit
results are meaningful because
they are comparably complete.
And that if they are
not comparably complete,
if for instance, the
accounting of cost
is much more complete than
the accounting of benefits,
then you have at
best, a lower bound
rather than a point estimate
of the exact right estimate.
So, you know, that's
also essentially
never recognized sometimes.
There's a throwaway
qualification
about what the unquantified
benefits might mean.
The question about how economic
benefits of job creation
are handled is a
separate puzzle.
This depends on the
macroeconomic theories
that one subscribes to.
Cost benefit analysis is
sometimes, but not necessarily
embedded in a
theory that assumes
free markets reach a state
of employment more or less
all the time.
Computer generally equilibrium
models, which essentially
conceal this assumption
behind waves of mathematics,
but assume that
labor markets clear.
Well, guess what?
If labor markets clear,
you don't create net jobs
by putting people to work.
There are essentially
no policy makers
in the country who actually
act as if they believe this.
I mean, are we creating local
jobs is a central question
for every policymaker.
So in that sense,
the calculation
is correct relative
to what people assume.
But not necessarily correct
relative to the theories.
The who should, the question
of is it worth doing this.
You know, does cost benefit
analysis on its own terms show
that it's worth
remediating versus what
does it show about development
are, as I think people noted,
are two separate questions.
And what it showed,
you know, is it worth
remediating is a question that
takes cost benefit analysis.
What should be developed
there strikes me
as probably a more
straightforward
financial calculation
about development.
Unless it has
environmental impacts
we haven't talked about.
Also the question
of who should, who
should pay versus who benefits,
are again, separate questions.
Cost benefit analysis
identifies, again
in its own terms, is it worth
it for society to do it,
not who should pay.
Should the people who benefit
the most from development
pay for it, is a policy question
about distribution of benefits.
If you were building
low income housing,
you would never suggest that
the people who benefited most
from low income housing
should pay the cost.
That's not the point
of low income housing.
The discounting question I think
applies in particular to health
costs, one of the
other debates--
Which my co-author, Lisa
Heinzerling particularly
has highlighted, is that
if you have diseases
that have a long latency
period, as you might
well in Superfund pollution.
Things that will show up 20,
30, 40 years after exposure,
do you discount them from the
time when the disease appears
or from the time when the
risk, the exposure occurs?
At a high discount
rate, this could
make a very large difference.
The government
practice has drifted
toward the more conservative
approach of discounting
from when the disease appears.
But the discourse of
risk which is involved,
seems to point to discounting
from the time when
the exposure happened, which
makes them look much larger.
LEE: Just expand on that,
because people I think
were a little fuzzy about
discounting in the first place.
AUDIENCE: I have
your slides if you
want one of those particular
slides brought up,
your discounting slides.
FRANK ACKERMAN: Well, let
me try just saying it once.
So discounting applies to cases
where the costs and benefits
happen at different years.
No one is indifferent between
whether costs or benefits
happen now or 10 years from now.
And so trying to
express everything
as an equivalent present value,
the farther in the future
it is, generally the less it
seems like it's worth today.
So if costs and benefits
happen at very different times,
as they do in many environmental
problems, the rate at which we
discount the future.
Right?
We can all agree that getting
paid far in the future
is worth less than getting
paid the same amount today.
But how much less is it worth?
What's the discount rate ?
Brings up, that will
affect essentially,
the trade-off between, the
price ratio between the future
and the present.
And so the more, the
higher the discount
rate, the more
unfavorable that is.
So one of the issues with the
kind of toxic health hazards
that arise in this
scenario in particular,
is that you can be
exposed to them today
and you know, cancer is
famous for, many cancers have
a very long latency
period before there's
any detectable disease.
But they come from exposures,
childhood exposures,
exposures decades earlier.
People have the, people who
immigrate internationally
have the cancer patterns of
the country they lived in
before they were 20 generally.
So even cancers
occur late in life.
So in that case, if you're
discounting the future
at a big value, you're exposed
today, you show signs of cancer
30 years from now.
Should we treat that as a harm
that was done to you today
when you were exposed?
Or a harm that was done to
you 30 years from now when you
had cancer?
At a high enough discount rate,
those would be very different.
AUDIENCE: For discounting,
does that only happen when you,
when the costs and
benefits are only looked
at for present day people?
Like if you include future
people in your accounting,
you no longer have discounting?
FRANK ACKERMAN: No.
Then you really
have discounting.
Because there's no
way for future people
to be at the table
and make decisions.
So I mean the decisions are
being made by today's people.
You don't know what
the future wants.
You don't know what the future's
willingness to pay will be.
So we're making
decisions about what we
think those things are worth.
And the farther in
the future they are,
the more we discount
them at a positive rate.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if we
have time to clarify this.
I'm wondering why,
I think we can
make a reasonable assumption
that for air pollution,
how much it matters to us.
The people in the future also
don't want air pollution.
They relate to air pollution at
least similarly to us, right?
There wouldn't be
discounting in that case?
FRANK ACKERMAN:
Well, I mean, people
who have thought
a lot about this,
and again, Mark Sagoff,
who Lee mentioned,
is a philosopher
who's looked at some
of this, who essentially
concluded we're
going to create the future.
If we preserve wild nature
and act like we value it,
we'll probably have
descendants who value that.
If we create a world that's
all paved and has strip malls
and excellent video
games, we'll probably
create descendants
who value that.
So it's like, there's
a circularity in that
what we do today will
actually create the future's
preferences.
So there is no way actually to
do something from a hypothesis
about what the future prefers,
because not only do they not
exist yet, but we
will create them.
LEE: We have two
minutes [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK ACKERMAN: Oh, my God.
So what do you do
with this refusal
of cost benefit analysis
for such excellent reasons
as Lee outlines?
You know, I think again,
separating in this story,
separating the cleanup
from the development,
there might be a stronger
case for the cleanup
and a weaker one
for development--
The more you're thinking about
these non-monetized values.
I think that I've
come to the conclusion
that despite the validity
of all those critiques
and the importance of
saying them every time
you get a chance, that if--
You have more than six
minutes to talk about one
of these things that
you have to then go
on and say using the prevailing
values, what would you get.
Try to avoid endorsing
them as a sign of,
you know, yes, we think this
is the greatest idea ever,
but saying--
I've ended up
saying using values
that have become conventional,
here's what you would conclude.
So in this case,
$35 million damage
is not very large
if you think it's
going to kill a few people.
Because values of life in
the $6 to $8 million range
have become conventional.
If we had more
time, I could tell
you how absurd the basis for the
$6 to $8 million per life is,
and the paradoxes
that come from that.
But given that that has become
semi standard in the policy
discourse, a policy that saves
a few lives predicatively
is clearly worth $35
million to society
in conventional
cost benefit terms.
So that things that
kind of hold your nose
and go with the lesser evil,
which American politics is
so full of, occurs here too.
LEE: Would that last
sentence, in a sense,
be adequate to just
say to the governor,
I think you don't need to spend
money on an elaborate analysis,
even using the prevailing values
of $6 to $7 million per person.
We undoubtedly would
save six or seven lives.
Maybe 60 or 70, maybe 600 or
700 in the course of this.
So we don't even need
to any further analysis.
FRANK ACKERMAN: I
think that's right.
If it's clear that it
saves a lot of lives,
and air pollution
often kills people.
So the things that
reduce air pollution
are particularly
successful in this.
There are a handful
of these values
that have become standard.
There's been an argument
that you shouldn't
allow other values, there's
been a very partisan discourse
about which values are allowed.
But the handful of values
which have been allowed,
create strong arguments
for some policies.
Superfund one's
actually are trickier
to demonstrate the number of
deaths than air pollution.
Air pollution so
clearly kills people
that it just doesn't have a
chance in these cost benefit
settings.
LEE: We will stop out
of respect for the fact
that you have to
study more economics.
Frank, thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]